What is up everyone?!
My name is Ashleigh.
And today's little video is based on an article
entitled: "Nail Biting a Problem Deeper than Skin Deep."
Now I'm sure a lot of us are guilty of biting our nails.
I know I am.
As a kid, I used to bite my fingernails a lot.
But nobody really pointed it out,
except for my aunt, and after she did,
I guess you could say that was when I started using a lot of nail polish.
And because I did use nail polish, it prevented me from biting my fingernails.
Because I do not want all of this hard work to go to waste.
Now according to the article,
there are many reasons why a person would want to bite their nails.
It can be attention seeking, sociopathy, lack of self monitoring, or self esteem
and it can even be OCD.
But the most common reasons are stress and anxiety.
It's used as an outlet for built up emotions
and a way to reduce tension.
In the article, Dr. Bronow says that our skin and nails are a mirror of our emotions.
It just got pretty deep, didn't it?
Now to conclude this video,
I would like to give you guys some tips on how you can stop yourselves from biting your nails.
Now the first thing you're going to have to do
is confront your problem, okay?
Admit it.
Admit that you have a problem with biting your nails.
Suggestion #1:
This is going to sound really ridiculous,
but as long as you're at home, I think you can get away with it.
You can wrap bandages around your fingernails.
Suggestion #2:
this is something you can get away with,
especially when you're outside with friends or at an occasion.
You can wear some stylish gloves.
For all of you lovely ladies out there,
like I mentioned in the first part of my video,
you can wear some nail polish.
And my last suggestion and
I think this is the best way you can stop biting your nails
is to keep your fingernails short.
Now if they're short,
there's going to be absolutely nothing for you to bite.
And that is my time.
Thank you so much for watching this video.
The link to the article:
"Nail Biting a Problem Deeper than Skin Deep"
is in the description box below.
Hi!
Thought you saw the last of me, didn't you?
I just wanted to remind all of you beautiful people
that you can find all of out content on our website psych2go.net.
Please follow our Tumblr page at psych2go.tumblr.com.
Please follow us here on our YT channel.
We will be posting videos based on the articles that are available on our website.
Please remember to give this video and all of our videos
a thumbs up to show your love and support.
Once again, thank you so much for watching this video
and I'll see you next time.